we look at the rapid growth of people
the Muslim faith look at the rapid
growth of the Asian and African
population and the difficulties many of
those societies face and what are we in
the developed so called developed
nations the world doing about that we
seem to be rather complacent rather
concerned with our own welfare our own
good Arlen wealth that's certainly true
of the United States equally true in
Europe great nation like Japan is not
doing nearly as much as it could and I
think there needs to become the idea of
the global leader the global citizen is
comfortable operating in any environment
whether they're in business and
government in non-profit organization
but they're really concerned about the
global problems of the world if the
Chinese are putting out dirty coal to
produce electricity to run their plans
that coal comes it that that pollution
comes into the United States if we run
out of energy and no ones are placing
that that's a problem that affects all
of us and so we need to address those
there's no way we can address problems
of global warming unless people come
together as one to address them there's
no way we can adjust problems of say
AIDS in Africa unless we come together
as one body to address those